zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live nach der explosion am
dienstag im chempark in leverkusen mit
mindestens fünf toten gibt es zwei große
fragen die dringend beantwortet werden
müssen die erste ist wie konnte es zu
diesem unglück eigentlich kommen was war
der auslöser und die zweite große frage
ist was war eigentlich in dieser wolke
die durch die explosion entstanden ist
und dann stundenlang über der stadt
stand und sich wahrscheinlich über die
nähere umgebung verteilt hat wie
gefährlich ist das ganze für die
anwohner das möchten viele menschen
wissen aber natürlich auch viele
menschen die nicht in leverkusen wohnen
weil das kann ja sein dass das ganze
auch noch weiter getragen wurde und auf
einmal diese beiden fragen auf die
letzte können wir eventuell gleich eine
antwort geben denn die stadt leverkusen
und das landesumweltamt nordrhein
westfalen werden eine pressekonferenz
geben in wahrscheinlich ungefähr zehn
bis 15 minuten geht das ganze los dann
schalten wir live drauf das werden wir
mit euch zusammen mit verfolgen und dann
danach mit einem toxikologen über die
ergebnisse über die erkenntnisse
sprechen uns das noch mal genauer
erklären lassen das heißt wie immer
könnt ihr uns fragen und kommentare in
die dafür vorgesehenen spalten packen
oder an diese e mail adresse zdf
heute.de zdf.de da werde ich dann
schauen was sich mit rein nehmen kann
aber zuerst schalten wir mal zu unserem
korrespondenten thomas münten nach
düsseldorf der das ganze mit uns
zusammen verfolgt hallo thomas hallo was
ist denn bis jetzt über den
unfallhergang eigentlich bekannt es war
eine verpuffung oder explosion im
tanklager dieser entsorgungsanlage die
gehört einer tochterfirma von bayer und
das ganze ist sozusagen eine
lösungsmittelhaltige stoff gewesen das
ist das was man uns gesagt hat
das problem an dieser entsorgungsanlage
ist dass sie auf der größten
giftmülldeponie europa steht seit 1923
wurden da giftstoffe abgekippt und 19 23
ist jetzt wirklich so lange her dass man
weiß darüber gibt es gar keine
unterlagen mehr was da genau liegt das
ist im großen und ganzen auch nicht so
schlimm gewesen weil die deponie nach
oben hin mit einem betondeckel
sie gilt war seit den späten 70ern erst
als zillmann aufgehört hat diese deponie
zu befüllen vorher hatte man auch schon
aufgehört es gab aber auch dieser
deponie tatsächlich eine wohnsiedlung
und dann gab es dort krankheiten
allergien die leute fühlten sich alle
nicht wohl das wurde untersucht und in
den kellern dieser wohnsiedlung hat man
dann so schadstoff kombinationen
gefunden dass die ganzen häuser wieder
abgerissen wurden das ganze wurde mit
einem betondeckel versiegelt prima fall
gelöst
jetzt aber ist es so dass diese
autobahnbrücke die genau an dieser
stelle über den rhein führt so marode
ist dass sie ersetzt werden muss und um
diese autobahnbrücke durch eine neue
dann zwölf spurige autobahnbrücke zu
ersetzen musste man in teile der deponie
wiederum löcher bohren und das was da
raus gekommen ist wurde dann so unsere
so hat man uns damals gesagt wir haben
vor drei jahren schon mal darüber
berichtet wurde daneben sollte in dieser
verbrennungsanlage entsorgt werden so
das heißt was da für eine schadstoff
kombination jetzt genau rund um dieses
tanklager gelagert hat weil er natürlich
in der nähe irgendwo diese zu verbrennen
schadstoffe auch lagern müssen das weiß
man gar nicht so genau insoweit das kann
alles sein
wir haben damals mal mit dem experten
gesprochen ich habe jetzt gerade noch
mal raus geholt und angeschaut da sind
sowohl sprengstoff reste aus der
sprengstoff produktion damals vergraben
worden
da sind kuranyi vergraben worden da es
ist ein mineralöle abgekippt worden
das ist eine ganz gefährliche mischung
und unser experte damals hat gesagt das
problem ist wenn man da ein loch im bug
vor der schippe ist es dunkel man weiß
nicht worauf man stößt und genau dieses
zeug wird dann zu dieser
müllverbrennungsanlage hingefahren und
wenn da was explodiert dann ist
natürlich das was da lagert das ist ein
trümmerfeld rund um diese anlage herum
immer mit betroffen also was und wie
wissen wir noch nicht wir werden ja froh
wenn wir wüssten was in dieser fetten
schwarzen wolke war die dann stundenlang
über leverkusen gestanden aber eben
durch die winde weil sie sehr nach oben
geschossen
durch die winde in den oberen
luftschichten bis nach dortmund getragen
das sind so gut 80 90 kilometer gut also
was die umwelt was diese deponie
tatsächlich jetzt damit zu tun hat
müssen daher noch mal gucken ob da
irgendwas zugesagt wird auf der
pressekonferenz unfallursache ist
bislang noch völlig unklar
man kann immer noch nicht wirklich dahin
nach dem was ich heute morgen gehört
habe
es werden ja das ist nagel mich nicht
darauf fest ich weiß nicht also wurden
ja immer noch zwei leute vermisse ich
weiß wenn man die inzwischen gefunden
hat es ist ein reines trümmerfeld um
diese reste der anlage herum und man ist
natürlich sehr vorsichtig man will ja
nicht einfach rein laufen weil auch da
natürlich schadstoffe ohne ende mai
gesetzt werden konnten
insoweit solange man nicht an die anlage
dann kommt weiß man natürlich zur
eigentlichen schadensursache ganz wenig
das ist dann echt spekulatius was man da
vermuten könnte aber klar ist wenn in
einer müllverbrennungsanlage in einer
sonder müllverbrennungsanlage was
explodiert dann ist das nicht besonders
umweltfreundlich das ist wahrscheinlich
selten gut wir gucken uns mal an was
nach der explosion geschah maike fahrrad
hat als wir uns mal zusammengefasst die
unglücksstelle nach der explosion in
diesen trümmern werden noch zwei
menschen vermisst
fünf menschen starben 31 wurden verletzt
die polizei konnte erst gestern mit
ihren ermittlungen zur ursache beginn
nach der explosion wurden anwohner
aufgefordert türen und fenster zu
schließen und nicht raus zu gehen denn
es war unklar wie giftig der rauch war
der über dem ruhrgebiet bis nach
dortmund schwebte die rußwolke war
voller oeliger partikel teilweise so
groß wie eine euro münze die in brand
geratenen tanks enthielten
produktionsrückstände von den
umliegenden chemiefirmen unter anderem
chlorierte lösungsmittel bei feuer
können diese zu hochgiftigen dioxinen
und pcb verbindungen werden spielplätze
wurden in einigen leverkusener
stadtteilen geschlossen anwohner wurden
gebeten ihr gemüse im garten erst einmal
nicht zu verzehren
das landesumweltamt hat proben der
rußpartikel entnommen das soll
aufschluss darüber geben wie schädlich
der rauch wirklich war
wir kommen jetzt die ersten kommentare
und fragen was genau ist eine verpuffung
ich habe im chemieunterricht zu halbwegs
aufgepasst aber nicht immer ich habe
gerade noch mal nachgeschaut man spricht
von einem relativ schnellen
verbrennungsvorgang dennoch keine
explosion ist aber dafür haben wir uns
dann gleich noch ein wissenschaftler
eingeladen den streams ökologen doktor
daniel professor daniel dietrich von der
uni konstanz der uns das hoffentlich
noch mal genauer erklären wird oder hast
du einen abschluss in chemie thomas von
kanzlers nochmal genauer erläutern
ich war ich war immer gut in chemie aber
so gut dann auch nicht aber wie gesagt
das ist alles was wir im moment da
vermuten wäre spekulation
das kann kurz gewesen seien das kann
alles möglich gewesen da muss man
wirklich abwarten bis die
brandsachverständigen der polizei und
der feuerwehr da ihre arbeit gemacht
haben
wenn man inzwischen ran kann umso besser
dann wird man das irgendwann ja
feststellen können wenn man stand eben
war das manchmal noch nicht an den
eigentlichen explosion oder verpuffung
sher drankommt und deswegen ist da keine
kindes gibt ist das auch der grund warum
immer noch zwei menschen vermisst werden
der grund scheint auch zu sein das was
eben im filmmuseum das ist ein
trümmerfeld das ist relativ große anlage
wieder zerstört worden ist da liegt ganz
viel zeug rum was man nicht einfach so
weg räumen kann wenn man den anwohnern
schon rein bitte fassen sie ihr gemüse
nicht mehr an was hier teilweise dann
monatelang liebevoll aufgezogen haben
dann weiß man dass direkt am
explosionsort man besser gar nichts
anfassen sollte natürlich ist die
feuerwehr auf solche sachen vorbereitet
aber es ist inzwischen eigentlich auch
allen klar dass man hier nicht mehr von
retten spricht sondern nur noch von
bergen und dass man dass die hoffnung
die beiden vermissten personen leben zu
finden natürlich eigentlich 0 sein muss
so schlimm das ist
ist denn schon bekannt wer die anderen
toten sind fünf sind es ja mittlerweile
an der zahl da gibt es bislang gar keine
nachrichten die mich jedenfalls erreicht
haben wahrscheinlich mitarbeiter
vielleicht auch an lieferbar
große fragezeichen ich hoffe dass die
pressekonferenz uns da jetzt gleich
weiterhilft ich sehe die hier auf einem
anderen monitor nebenbei
es ist hat man nicht angefangen aber
sind quasi alle vorbereitet so dass wir
dann gleich unter anderem eben den
oberbürgermeister sehen werden aber auch
die krisenstabs leiterin und vor allen
dingen jemand vom landesumweltamt denn
das ist ja das wichtige was genau war
jetzt da drin es können ja auch kontakt
gestanden sein
deswegen eben die aufforderung auch an
die leute die diese rußpartikel in ihren
gärten haben oder auf ihren spielgeräten
haben bitte nicht selbst abwischen
sondern die stadt verständigen
die dann mit speziellen teams kommen und
das saubermachen
das kann schon auswendig werden
wahrscheinlich so ganze gärten zu
reinigen thomas direkt betroffen sind
hier die anwohner hast du gerade schon
gesagt eben deswegen weil sie drum herum
wohnen und dieses gift volker ausgesetzt
sind oder waren
wir haben mal geschaut was die
eigentlich zu der jetzigen situation zu
sagen man schon gesagt nur gekriegt hat
fenster zu führen zu in der wohnung
bleiben also das ist schon was
gefährliches ich bin beunruhigt ob alles
in ordnung ist ob das noch mal passieren
kann ja wie gesagt wenn man hat angst
ich meine ist redet erst einmal passiert
ist das schon den 90er jahren schon mal
was passiert auch der oft entsorgen und
gut damit muss man leben
wir haben uns daran gewöhnt dass es ab
und zu ein ereignis gibt in
anführungszeichen ich glaube dass es
hier in dieser in diesem bereich keine
sicherheitsvorkehrungen gibt außer dass
man eben sein haus so weit mit fenstern
ausgestattet hat die recht sind
rollläden und so weiter aber ansonsten
sehr stark keine möglichkeiten
tja also das ist ein gewisser fatalismus
erich da fast raus thomas ist das normal
im ruhrgebiet dass man sagt okay hier
ist chemie hier sind schwierige sachen
das passiert einfach mal ich sag mal so
wer in leverkusen wohnt der muss mit
bayer leben weil diese stadt ist im
endeffekt ja eigentlich um das werk
herum entstanden und lebt natürlich auch
vom werk und es geht er ja eigentlich
mit den einkünften mit den
arbeitsplätzen dieses bauwerkes und
dieses chemparks dort recht gut
das ist im ruhrgebiet genauso wie er im
ruhrgebiet
persönlich bin in duisburg aufgewachsen
der in diesmal wohnt der wusste wenn die
große schwarze wolke kommt dann geht man
rein und dann rennen alle raus und holen
schnell noch die wäsche von der leine
das hat natürlich inzwischen dem
ruhrgebiet völlig nachgelassen da
passiert so was nicht mehr aber in der
nähe einer solchen müllverbrennung muss
man quasi haben wir ab der gerade haben
wir gerade gehört man muss damit rechnen
dass es immer wieder diese ereignisse
gibt nichts funktioniert wirklich
fehlerfrei aber so ein ereignis wie wir
jetzt gesehen haben dass hat es
tatsächlich ja in den letzten 20 30
jahren nicht gegeben nicht in dieser
stärke
bevor ich jetzt hier geprügelt werde
leverkusen gehört offiziell nicht zum
ruhrgebiet müsste ich also pflanzen ist
eigentlich rheinland aber ist so groß
gebiet aber thomas das war nicht das
einzige ereignis gab er am 21 juli schon
mal einen harmlosen produkt austritt so
hieß das damals dort vor ort da soll da
schreibt eine große boulevard-zeitung
ein wärmeaustauscher explodiert wurde
seien auch mit einem großen knall damals
weißt du da mehr über diesen vorfall nur
dass es eben auch genau das hieße es
hieß es ist ein gerät explodiert oder
zerstört worden es kam zu einem
harmlosen produkt austritt innerhalb der
anlage der von der natürlich
vorgeschriebenen werkfeuerwehr dann da
bekämpft wurde ohne dass es da
irgendwelche großen folgen gab das ist
das was ich in der in den letzten
stunden an da zu recherchieren konnte
aber auch da es gibt wahrscheinlich kein
kein so groß dimensioniertes industrie
gespinst ohne dass da mal irgendwas
kaputt geht dafür gibt es ja eben solche
vorgeschriebenen
sicherheitseinrichtungen und
werksfeuerwehren um das im zaum zu
halten
insoweit ja das mal so kleinigkeiten
passieren ja das lässt sich
wahrscheinlich nicht vermeiden aber das
hat man ja damals alles relativ gut
absichern können nur jetzt kamen
wirklich jede sicherung zu spät aber
auch mehr nur auf die bilder oder als
ich an die bilder erinnern die wir
gerade gesehen haben
wenn dann der kilometer hohe rauchwolke
schwarz fettig über die stadt zieht dann
weiß eigentlich jeder leverkusener schon
fenster türen zu und am besten
nicht ausgehen also hier im stream gibt
es auch natürlich jetzt viel
aufrichtiges beileid für die
hinterbliebenen für die familien der
todesopfer
sabine schreibt es ein furchtbares
unglück hoffe den verletzten geht es
bald wieder gut ohne bleibenden schäden
das sind ja auch eine ganze menge
verletzte also weit über zwei dutzend
glaube ich ja und über deren
gesundheitszustand erfahren wir im
moment auch recht wenig ist aber auch
verständlich die leute haben andere
sorgen oder die die angehörigen sollen
ja auch nicht dauernd damit konfrontiert
werden
ich glaube auch für die ist wirklich
wichtig dass man dahinter kommt wie
gefährlich war das und wie konnte es
dazu kommen
über den aktuellen gesundheitszustand
habe ich jetzt heute mittag nichts neues
gehört also das war der stand fünf tote
zwei vermisste
und ich glaube 22 verletzte das wird
auch sicherlich irgendwann mal geklärt
werden was für verletzungen da gab aber
das spielt jetzt im moment auch für die
ermittlungen keine rolle sondern drücken
die daumen eben dass die verletzten die
auch teilweise schwer verletzt sind es
wirklich schaffen ob der folgen zurück
bleiben auch das kann man jetzt
natürlich überhaupt nicht abschätzen
so steht man sagen wir schauen mal kurz
in die pressekonferenz ob es da schon
was geht ob sich da irgendetwas bewegt
das kultus aufgebaut wir sehen auch
schon namen die da sprechen werden
andrea deppe als krisenstabs weiteren
und uwe richert als oberbürgermeister
von leverkusen aber noch ist niemand auf
dem podium
gucken wir nochmal in die kommentare
hier auch von natalie die schreibt auch
sie ist anwohnerin wir leben neben bayer
roche dsm und co und uns war schon immer
klar wenn was passiert kann es schlecht
enden jetzt ist natürlich die frage wie
würdest du jetzt diesen vorfall
einschätzen thomas da war natürlich groß
er war dramatisch aber hätte das ganze
ich meine das ist ein gesamtes ein
gesandter chemiepark mit vielen firmen
das hätte doch noch schlimmer ausgehen
können oder das hätte deutlich schlimmer
ausgehen können natürlich betroffen ist
ja jetzt nur diese müllentsorgungsanlage
erst einmal
und wie gesagt wir müssen nur darüber
reden worauf diese oder woran diese
müllentsorgungsanlage grenzt das hätte
deutlich schlimmer enden können
und es ist
einfach in einem so dicht bebauten
gelände wie diesem camp hat in
leverkusen oder eben auch wie im
ruhrgebiet in duisburg hochfeld wo
firmen firma an firma steht wo die
grillo werke auch chemie produzent sind
man muss bei jedem dieser vorfälle
vorsichtig sein aber der hier war jetzt
schon so groß dass man darüber
nachdenken muss irgendwie was könnte man
in einem solchen fall tun hat die
warnung gut geklappt für die leute das
muss man vielleicht sagen das hat
einigermaßen gut funktioniert klar so
eine schwarze rauchwolke über der stadt
die sieht natürlich dann auch irgendwann
jeder mann wird mit diesen
industrieanlagen leben ist man kann
immer wieder weiter versuchen die
sicherheit zu verbessern
aber auch da müssen wir uns ja müssen
uns schon klar machen wir leben in so
einem industriestaat und irgendwo muss
diese industrie stehen und man muss
damit leben muss alles tun damit die
sicher ist man muss alles tun damit die
leute die in unmittelbarer umgebung ja
wohnen und teilweise in diesen firmen
arbeiten eine hohe sicherheit haben aber
ganz vermeiden wird man das
wahrscheinlich eben nicht hin
hier geht es dabei dann auch jetzt
kommentare bei uns drin die sagen also
ja dieses werk war zuerst tag weil sie
danach sind die siedlungen gekommen aber
auch kritische kommentare die anmerken
ich muss mal kurz gucken das waren was
mit windrädern das ist ja auch so eine
diskussion in nordrhein westfalen
gewesen dürfen solche anlagen näher an
siedlungen gebaut werden als windräder
möchte ralf dominik wissen hat sich die
landesregierung eigentlich dazu mal
geäußert da gab es doch viel ärger auch
gerade von der opposition die sich
beschwerte dass die regierung lasse
diese 1000 meter diesen 1000 meter
abstand zu siedlungen für windräder
jetzt auch umsetzen will auch sehr
konsequent umsetzen will
wurde da irgendwie das zugesagt in dem
zusammenhang neben dem zusammenhang gar
nichts ich habe in einem gespräch mit
armin laschet in einer in einer
diskussionssendung gehört dass man diese
1000 meter regeln nochmal grundsätzlich
andenken wolle oder dass man darüber
noch mal sprechen wolle
das ist das einzige was ich dir dazu
sagen kann da habe ich mich tatsächlich
mit dem thema windräder in dem
zusammenhang aber auch nicht befasst sie
gucken noch mal in die kommentare weil
gibt es noch ein paar fragen
genau um die geht es jetzt hier zum
beispiel von silvia die möchte wissen
wie giftig weiß jemand wie giftig dass
für die menschen ist und das ist genau
eine frage so jetzt habe ich auch die
markierung das ist genau die frage die
wir hoffen dass sie gleich geklärt wird
von der pressekonferenz der stadt
leverkusen und dem landesumweltamt
nordrhein westfalen der krisenstab
leiterin ist auch angemeldet wird sich
auch äußern wir hoffen dann dass es
erkenntnisse dazu gibt's was in der
wolke genau drin war und wie giftig das
ganze das dann ist das wollen wir auch
nachher besprechen mit dem toxikologen
professor daniel dietrich von der uni
konstanz jetzt gibt es hier noch mal
eine frage von sei jetzt der frage wer
kommt eigentlich für die entstandenen
schäden auf der chempark betreiber
selbst ist das eine frage thomas die
schon geklärt wurde die schon erörtert
wurde oder ist das gerade auch noch eine
sache die hinten angestellt wurde
ja gut frage wer kommt eigentlich müsste
dafür aufkommen der betreiber dieses der
sammel entsorgungsanlage weil der ist ja
für die sicherheit einer anlage
verantwortlich also currenta in dem fall
und darüber hinaus wie in wie weit man
die chempark betreiber die chempark
firmen dafür mit verantwortlich machen
kann
ich persönlich würde das jetzt aus dem
aus der reporter erfahrung nicht glauben
ich denke da wird currenta in erster
linie für verantwortlich sein das wird
übrigens wie du eben schon sagt sind
relativ teurer spaß werden weil dieses
reinigen der gärten dieses reinigen der
spielgeräte das ganze gemüse der
kleingärtner das weggeschmissen werden
muss ja höchstwahrscheinlich dass die
aber dann noch nicht mal selber
entsorgen dürfen sondern wahrscheinlich
auch von speziell gekleideten leuten
entsorgt werden muss das ist natürlich
ein riesen kosten summe die da auf den
verursacher dieses brand ist dieser
explosion dieser verpuffung was auch
immer das jetzt genau war zukommt und da
kann man nur hoffen dass alle gut
versichert sind die damit zu tun haben
klar ist dass das für die leute
abgesehen von dem materiellen schaden
natürlich auch
ja ein ganz schlimmes gefühl hinterlässt
stell dir vor du wohnst irgendwie ja wie
weit ist das vielleicht zwei kilometer
drei kilometer von dieser anlage
entfernt
sie ist die immer und dann warst du
dabei als diesen knall gab und diese
schwarze wolke über die stadt zog der
das hinterlässt schon eine unsicherheit
vor drei jahren als wir da gedreht haben
haben wir mit leuten gesprochen die
gesagt haben denn die auch nur anfangen
in diese deponie hinein zu bohren dann
ziehen wir weg vielleicht ist es jetzt
bei dem ein oder anderen auch so dass
ich sag mir dieses risiko jetzt haben
wir es vielleicht sogar will überstanden
aber dieses risiko weiter eingehen will
ich nicht und deshalb kann es durchaus
sein dass der ein oder andere überlegt
den stadtteil oder auch die stadt zu
verlassen und irgendwo anders hin zu
ziehen wo man eben nicht direkt in der
nähe solcher anlagen wohnt gezogen hast
du gesagt jetzt eine frage von michael
ackermann noch mal kurz zeigen
ich würde gern wissen ob die
schadstoffwolke bis nach essen gelangt
ist und wenn ja gab es darauf folgend
auch schadstoffbelasteten niederschlag
in essen
thomas kannst du da irgendwas zu sagen
es gab vom deutschen es gab vom
deutschen wetterdienst während des
brandes eine meldung dass die wolke
richtung dortmund gezogen sei ich bin
jetzt kein meteorologie oder
wetterexperte da müssen wir mal die
frage oder aber im grossen ganzen wenn
die bis nach dortmund gekommen ist dann
muss ja irgendwie dahin gelangt sein sie
kann natürlich über das bergische land
bis nach dortmund gezogen sein dann wäre
das ruhrgebiet verschont geblieben
und ich glaube das ist auch so gewesen
weil ich habe jetzt wie gesagt bei mir
zu hause in duisburg und in mülheim wo
ich war gab es keinen niederschlag in
irgendeiner form keinen dreckigen
insoweit könnte es sein dass die wolke
diese richtung normal bis dortmund ist
sie auf jeden fall gekommen
jetzt geht es der beschwerde von heidi
auf facebook nur geschwätz nichts
konkretes einfach traurig liebe heidi
wir warten darauf dass wir konkrete
erkenntnisse bekommen bis dahin müssen
wir uns ein bisschen eben mit
spekulationen teilweise begnügen oder
auch einfach mit der antwort von unserem
korrespondenten thomas münten düsseldorf
kann ich gerade noch nicht sagen weil
eben die behörden die offiziell noch
nicht wirklich mitgeteilt haben was in
der wolke drin war wo die genau
hingezogen ist welche mit gebiete
betroffen sind wie schädlich das ganz
für anwohnerinnen und anwohner auch im
größeren bereich gewesen ist das
erhoffen wir uns alle gleich von der
pressekonferenz deswegen bitte ich dich
und alle anderen noch mal ein bisschen
geduld die wird leicht los gehen wir
können auch mal kurz rüber schalten uns
das bild angucken da ist da passiert
tatsächlich noch nicht so viel außer
dass ein einsamer tontechniker seit
gefühlt zehn minuten die mikrofone hin
und her rückt aber wir gehen davon aus
also angemeldet was ich für 14.30 das
heißt es kann jetzt nicht mehr allzu
lange dauern
im hintergrund wird dann meistens noch
abgestimmt wer was wie wo sagt aber ich
denke das kann jetzt nicht mehr allzu
lange dauern dass das ganze losgeht
thomas wir haben ja schon gesprochen
darüber wie es den menschen da geht wir
müssen gesehen so leicht fatalistisch
waren einige trotzdem wie hat sich denn
die landesregierung als eigentlich
generell zu diesem vorfall geäußert die
landesregierung hat das gesagt was sie
sagt natürlich erstmal große
betroffenheit mitgefühl mit den
verletzten beileid für die familien der
verstorbenen und man werde alles tun um
den sachverhalt aufzuklären
und dann stellt sich die frage da was
zieht man die konsequenzen daraus
wenn man jetzt feststellte das ist ein
systemfehler in dieser ganzen
entsorgungslogistik drin dann wird man
irgendeiner form natürlich auch
politisch handeln müssen
aber ansonsten ist ja dieser eigentliche
vorgang dass oder die der eigentliche
betrieb des chemparks mit der
entsorgungsanlage hintendran im rahmen
aller genehmigungen erlaubt und
funktioniert ja auch und was da
rauskommt auch da warten wir wieder
darauf erstmal die unglücksursache genau
zu wissen und wer mehr die wissen dann
wird die landesregierung sicherlich auch
in irgendeiner form reagieren müssen
aber im moment kann man denke ich auch
nicht mehr erwarten als dass sie sagen
wir sind in gedanken bei den verletzten
wir trauern mit den hinterbliebenen und
wir versuchen die unglücksursache über
die ermittelnden behörden polizei
feuerwehr brandsachverständige so
schnell wie möglich aufzuklären
es gibt hier jetzt auch schon
anmerkungen
hundertprozentige sicherheit geht es
einfach nicht davon
hubert horstmann auf facebook der sagt
es sind auch schon tanklastzüge in
innenstädten explodiert das in die
kanalisation gelaufen um benzin hat aus
den kanaldeckeln granaten gemacht lama
auf herborn und an den vorfall erinnern
ich mich nicht aber die schlussfolgerung
ist absolut richtig einen absoluten
schutz gibt es einfach in einer
industrialisierten welt aber auch
generell einfach nicht naturkatastrophen
passieren auch das wissen wir alle
die gab es noch eine frage zu den grünen
von günter jankowski ob sie sich dazu
geäußert haben fabrik schließen oder
abreißen
er meint die müssten jetzt am rad drehen
was da für dreck in die luft gegangen
ist und er spricht sein beileid aus also
hat sich die grüne opposition da
irgendwie zu geäußert da halt nicht dass
ich wüsste bis jetzt das ist aber auch
alles noch viel zu früh natürlich ist er
wäre das wäre das wenn man irgendwelche
systemischen fehler nachweisen könnte im
wahlkampf thema sicherlich für die
grünen aber im moment habe ich da noch
gar nicht zugehört was gerade rein
gekommen ist habe ich gesehen die stadt
leichlingen im rheinisch bergischen
kreis hat jetzt auch zur absoluten
vorsicht im umgang mit sozusagen obst
und gemüse aus der elf aus dem eigenen
anbau aufgerufen das schreiben sie noch
schuhe sollten vor dem gang in die
wohnung ausgezogen werden man sollte die
hände waschen man solle tun ist sich
nicht direkt auf den rasen legen also
auch die umliegenden gemeinden reagieren
natürlich darauf weil man eben nicht
ganz sicher ist wie weit und wohin diese
wolke gezogen ist
bis nach dortmund ist sie gekommen da
steht fest aber wie und auf welchem weg
auch das weiß ich jetzt von hier aus
nicht eigentlich auch nur entschuldigen
aber das war bis jetzt auch nicht so
klar festzustellen so jetzt geht es noch
eine beschwerde an meine richtung von
viola die meint ich hätte nur armen von
geografie das ist richtig das muss ich
leider einfach offen so zu geben und ich
verwechsle auch mal nord und süden das
ist mir am montag passiert das wird es
mir jetzt noch mal vor und sie meinte
schlimm dass ich mich heute noch nicht
vernünftig informiert habe wir haben uns
soweit informierte konnten aber liebe
viola es gibt einfach relativ wenig
informationen von seiten der behörden
bis heute
das ist in solchen unglücksfällen aber
nicht selten thomas nicht das erste mal
einfach eine informationssperre kommt
und dann nichts bekannt wird
wäre ja ich meine ist ja auch logisch
wer möchte sich da jetzt gegen ihn in
die nesseln setzen und irgendwas
bekanntgeben oder irgendwen öffentlich
verantwortlich machen man muss hier auch
vorstellen es entsteht ja dann
sicherlich das letzte woran man denken
muss somit aber es entsteht ja dann ein
wirtschaftlicher schaden wenn man wenn
wir jetzt gingen würde sagen der und der
ist verantwortlich oder dies und jenes
firma ist verantwortlich und stellt
dafür das wäre dann ein aktien geführtes
unternehmen
dann würden wir dafür vielleicht dafür
sorgen dass diese aktion kurs verliert
und der dann entstandene schaden wer
wäre dafür verantwortlich im endeffekt
ja wir oder die behörden wenn die das
getan hätten und deswegen ist jeder
absolut vorsichtig und wird sich erst zu
den folgen zu den konsequenzen äußern
ganz klar fest steht wie ist die
explosion erfolgt was wurde freigesetzt
wie viel aufwand ist notwendig um das
alles wieder sauber zu kriegen muss man
vielleicht sogar erde abtragen es könnte
auch sein es könnte ja sein dass die
stoffe gar nicht sozusagen von rasen
oder von spielplatz flächen zu entfernen
sind dass man da den untergrund komplett
austauschen muss all das kann passieren
das hängt eben davon ab was wir jetzt
gerade erhoffen uns auf dieser
pressekonferenz zu erfahren was genau in
diesem rauch in die luft geblasen wurde
arbeiten sofort die öffentlichkeit ist
ungeduldig das können wir verstehen wir
journalisten sind auch immer sehr
ungeduldig möchten auch immer als erstes
genau die fragen beantwortet haben die
ihn stellt aber ganz häufig bekommen wir
dann einfach zuhören wissen wir noch
nicht oder können wir noch nicht sagen
manchmal stellt sich dann hinter heraus
dass das nicht ganz der wahrheit
entsprochen hat dass man hätte schon was
sagen können aber dass es dann einfach
auch politische gründe gibt aber ganz
häufig ist es einfach so dass solche
erkenntnisse einfach dauern ja man kann
nicht einfach ein stift in die luft
halten man weiß eine halbe stunde später
was drin war sondern das sind
hochkomplexe chemische analysen gemacht
werden das lassen wir uns nicht noch mal
erklären von toxikologen professor
dieter daniel dieter von der uni
konstanz
ich habe gerade aufs ohr gesagt bekommen
dietrich von professor daniel dietrich
von der uni konstanz ich hab grad von
der meiner kollegin in der regierung
sword gesagt bekommen dass die
pressekonferenz teilnehmer teilweise
noch im stau stehen und es deswegen zu
einer
verzögerung der pressekonferenz kommt
das heißt wir haben jetzt glaube ich
erst mal alle fragen mit thomas münten
in düsseldorf geklärt ich schaue noch
mal aufs von euch irgendwelche fragen
gibt die wir versuchen können zu
beantworten aber ich merke ja schon wenn
wir versuchen fünf erreichen so
beantworten wo es keine konkrete antwort
darauf gibt dann beschwert ihr euch auch
wieder kann ich auch verstehen
deswegen wollen wir das jetzt mal
einfach hier sein lassen würde ich sagen
thomas oder und dann warten wenn man auf
die pressekonferenz und schalten auf das
pressekonferenz bild und ich bitte euch
einfach ein paar minuten geduld könnten
chat und das bild hier offen lassen und
wir sind dann gleich wieder da wenn es
losgeht dankeschön
[Musik]
ich bin hammam
ich kann nicht mehr
ich werde meine kamera
wenn du mit der kohle
durch technik und spezifischer umsetzen
das ist ein anfang
man gibt eine frage von stunden aus wir
helfen fragestunden
[Musik]
der dürfte noch einmal
du schaffst das
sie besuchen
bei mehr als zwei straßen vorsteht zwei
straßen vorher war schluss
so und wie wir sehen bewegt sich was bei
der pressekonferenz in leverkusen zu dem
unfall von dienstag im chempark
leverkusen mit insgesamt mittlerweile
fünf toten zwei menschen werden noch
vermisst die hoffnungen die chancen die
leben zu finden sind gleich null das
heißt da geht es im endeffekt nur noch
ums bergen aber wie wir von unserem
korrespondenten in düsseldorf thomas
münten soeben gehört haben ist es wohl
relativ schwierig noch an die
unglücksstelle heranzukommen eben auch
wegen der vermutlichen gift gefahr was
in der giftwolke drin gewesen ist was
bei der explosion frei gesetzt worden
ist diese antworten erhoffen wir uns
jetzt bei dieser pressekonferenz die
damen und herren machen sich gerade auf
dem podium bereit anwesend habe ich
gerade gesehen sind zum beispiel der
oberbürgermeister vertreter des
landesumweltamtes nordrhein westfalen
die krisenstabs leiterin
das heißt da werden wir jetzt gleich
sehen und hören was sie zu sagen haben
und danke für die hinweise von euch im
chat dass die mikrofone
bei der pressekonferenz während gewartet
wurde noch offen waren das ist ein
hinweis den nehmen wir gerne mit
da wurden dann private gespräche gehört
das soll so nicht sein das heißt das
nächste mal machen wir das zu haben wir
dann auch nachträglich gemacht aber
jetzt geht es erstmal los schalten nach
leverkusen
in der richter die oberbürgermeister
kennen die meisten von ihnen die von
apple durch die krisen schlagen würde
ich den fall gewesen und daher kennen
von currenta ich hab die dritte
weitergegeben
vielen dank
ja müssen ja leider beklagen dass fünf
menschen verstorben sind zwar vermisste
und 31 verletzten ich habe das schon
gesagt das ist ein dramatischer moment
für die dass wir warten jetzt geht es
natürlich darum schaden von den bürgern
abzulehnen jetzt kommen auch die ersten
ergebnisse rein aber weiterhin geht es
natürlich darum weitere risiken
auszuschließen das wird auch heute
bestand hat auch der das pressegespräch
ist sein dass auch zu erläutern wie wir
weiter vorgehen
der schutz der bevölkerung steht hier im
mittelpunkt aber meine gedanken sind
natürlich weiterhin eine familien der
verstorbenen person mit dieser
einführung richtig gerne krisenstabs
leiterin andrea dippel das wort erteilen
um ihnen die situation weiter zu
erläutern
muss ich lauter dann reden mit oscar ok
ja auch von meiner seite herzlich
willkommen zu unserem pressegespräch
sie haben es gehört ich war zu dem
zeitpunkt krisenstabsleiter hin
der krisenstab ist hierbei der
feuerwache sofort zusammengekommen
daran beteiligt sind dann immer polizei
lanuf die heute dabei sind umweltamt
grünflächenamt straßenverkehr
gesundheitsamt also und alle anderen
fachbereiche sitzen bei uns im
hintergrund um jederzeit dann abgerufen
werden zu können
das land war von beginn an mit bei uns
im boot
wir haben eine enge zusammenarbeit
gehabt und eine große unterstützung
durch ihre fachkenntnis dafür möchte ich
mich an dieser stelle noch einmal ganz
herzlich auch bedanken bei aller
dramatik und tragik des ereignisses
stehen bei uns momentan natürlich die
klärung und bewältigung der brandfolgen
im fokus in diesem zusammenhang wollen
wir so schnell wie möglich für die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieser stadt
informationen weitergeben informieren
denn uns ist klar dass viele auch
verängstigt sind und in sorge sind
deshalb sind wir sehr dankbar dass wir
heute die ersten ergebnisse zu
mindestens mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen des bahnhofs in mitteilen
können und auch natürlich mitteilen
können welche maßnahmen daraus getroffen
werden
ich würde deshalb ganz gerne jetzt
erstmal weitergeben an dr klasse auch
wieder
einen schönen guten tag ich bin jetzt
heute hier um über die laborergebnisse
zu berichten die wir im wesentlichen
darüber wie wir eben anhand der partikel
funde die hier natürlich den unfall in
der umgebung niedergegangen sind gemacht
haben nicht aber ganz kurz eben einen
darauf eingehen wir waren vom ladung
sondereinsatz
einige zeit nach der explosion durch die
feuerwehr alarmiert worden und haben
dann zunächst mit unserem großen
messfahrzeug luft analysen gemacht
imponiert dem stadtteil rheindorf und
später dann im stadtteil bürrig um
festzustellen ob eben durch die
explosion luftschadstoffe gasförmiger
luftschadstoff freigesetzt worden sind
diese messungen waren alle unauffällig
ebenso messungen die die feuerwehr
selbst im stadtgebiet und ausbreitung
gebiet der rauchgas fahrende gemacht hat
so dass von daher zunächst mann der
entwarnung gegeben werden konnte
trotzdem wurde dann im laufe des tages
weiterhin die vorsorgemaßnahme dass die
bürger sich bitte in geschlossenen
räumen geschlossenen türen und fenstern
aufhalten sollten aufrechterhalten war
ja noch nachlöscharbeiten stattfanden
und eben auch maßnahmen ergriffen wurden
das nicht auch vor ausgasungen aus den
defekten tank irgendwelche einwirkungen
hatten es im laufe des nachmittags
trafen dann zunehmend bürger meldungen
vor allen dingen aus dem stadtteil durch
den weiteren verlauf dann auch aus den
stadtteilen die weiter nordwestlich
lagen dass partikel niederschläge zu
verzeichnen waren und wir sind dann eben
mit unserem probenahme team heraus
gefahren und haben im stadtteil buer ich
mehrere mit punkte begangen und in
augenschein genommen
wir konnten diese partikel niederschläge
detektieren auch in unterschiedlicher
länge je nachdem wo wir wo wir waren
es waren der auffällige partikel
insofern als sie recht groß waren also
millimeter bis zehn stücke euro stücke
groß einige
auch größere brocken waren auch zu sehen
wir haben allerdings wenig an typischen
russ filmen entdecken können und haben
dann geben diese partikel beprobt an
zwei orten und eben auch eine
gesprungene und über die ergebnisse
würde ich jetzt berichten
und da kann ich erfreuliche sagen im
gegensatz zu gehen fürchten und
erwartungen die wir eben aufgrund der
mitteilung hatten dass da eben auch
chlorierte kohlenwasserstoffe verbrannt
sind haben wir jetzt keine kritischen
werte an dioxin und pcb gefunden wir
sind mit den dioxinen und pcb im
wesentlichen im bereich der blind werte
und hintergrund werte teilweise
unterhalb unserer verfassungs und
bestimmungsgrenze und somit ist das
eigentlich eine gute nachricht dass
diese partikel von daher nicht wirklich
kritisch sind
wir haben die partikel auch vor
untersucht auf andere substanzen mit
spektrale analytischen methoden dabei
ist aber nichts herausgekommen weil die
einfach zu ist das licht absorbiert und
wir haben auch einen ph-wert
untersuchung gemacht um festzustellen ob
die partikel wir gehen jedenfalls sauer
oder basisch sind und haben dabei im
festgestellt die sind tatsächlich
ziemlich sauer gewesen
die weitere komponente außer dioxin und
pcb die wir untersucht haben sind die
polyzyklischen aromatische gruppen die
bei jeder verbrennung von feststoffen
oder flüssigen brennstoffen entstehen
auch diese werte die wir da haben sind
gering sie sind messbar aber sie sind im
unteren bereich dessen was man erwarten
kann bei solchen rosen und insofern auch
gesundheitlich und auch umwelt mäßig
unkritisch von dieser seite her können
wir also jetzt sagen dass die partikel
keine langlebigen und besonders
umweltrelevanten schadstoffe aufweisen
wir wissen aber natürlich noch nicht ob
es eventuell weitere stoff freisetzungen
gegeben hat die wir eben jetzt noch
nicht
essen konnten in der kurzen zeit und wo
wir auch noch nicht wussten und nachher
zu suchen hätten da wir erst jetzt die
ersten informationen bekommen haben und
welche stoffe er sich bei den tanklagern
eigentlich handelte ja das soweit zu den
ergebnissen
wir werden den bericht vermutlich jetzt
noch an diesem wochenende fertigstellen
und dann eben nächste woche im internet
verfügbar haben so dass sich jeder über
details genau informieren kann
das erste mal von meiner seite
ja ich möchte ergänzen was den akws
vorgestellt hat für uns und sicherlich
auch für die bevölkerung in leverkusen
erfreulich ist dass eben die rußpartikel
die untersucht wurden keine
überschreitungen der bewertungs grenzen
für dioxine für pkk oder pcb aufgreifen
das wäre sicherlich ein anlass an der
stelle zu sagen man hebt auch sämtliche
vorsorgemaßnahmen auf wir haben der
stadt leverkusen geraten dies nicht zu
tun weil wir der herr quast schon gesagt
hat wir bis heute im prinzip nicht
wussten welche stoffe in den tanks
tatsächlich gelagert sind und wir
einfach auch da noch weitere
untersuchungen durchführen möchten und
ich kann betont wirklich absolut
vorsichtshalber und wirklich mit sehr
viel bedürfnis sicherheit der stadt
leverkusen aufzugeben und das auch dann
in abstimmung mit der currenta zu tun
die auch messungen durchführt also da
die untersuchung die messung auch
abzustimmen zu synchronisieren zu gucken
welche dinge sind da festgestellt worden
und das mit einem eigenen
untersuchungsprogramm auch zu begleiten
um dann auch zu sagen auch durch die
vorhergehende explosion sind nicht mit
irgendwelchen stoffen die stadtteile in
leverkusen beauftragt worden
also eine wirkliche vorsichtsmaßnahme an
der stelle zu sagen wir halten oder wir
entschlagen vor
die vorsichtsmassnahmen da auch noch
aufrecht zu erhalten bis wir auch da an
der stelle entsprechende sicherheit
haben dass keine gefährdung für die
bürger entstehen
jedermann deren guten tag auch von mir
wenn man über gesundheitliche
folgewirkungen von und ereignissen
spricht dann denke ich sollte man
zunächst sich doch vergegenwärtigen dass
eine wirkliche gefahr im landläufigen
verständnis des begriffs für menschen in
solchen situationen sich auf den
brandherd und in unmittelbarer nähe
bereich beschränkt wie wir ja in dem
konkreten fall jetzt in sehr sehr
tragischer weise erneut erleben mussten
da kann es zu schadstoffkonzentrationen
kommen
das wissen sie alle die klassischen
brandgase die also erstickung zur folge
haben können
das ist abgesehen also von der
eigentlichen gefährdung durch den brand
natürlich tatsächlich dann eine
unmittelbare gefahr ist vielleicht
trivial aber ich lege doch wer drauf da
eine abgrenzung vorzunehmen zudem
worüber wir ansonsten sprechen nämlich
über risiken immer risiken langfristiger
natur
mendig auf chronische toxizität und zwar
in einer größenordnung bereich ganz das
gilt ganz generell in aller regel
verbrennen verbrannt ereignisse in einem
größenordnung bereich der vorsorge
zuzuordnen ist und wenn sich um
organische chemie handelt dann sind da
in erster linie die eben schon genannten
stoffgruppen von belang dioxine pc bkk
das sind dass ich so sagen die kraft des
bösen
vor der zu recht eine sorge dann immer
besteht
und da können wir nach dem was sie
gerade gehört haben von den
sachverständigen des lan hofs von den
wissenschaftlichen sachverständigen
können wir jetzt sagen dass wir in
dieser hinsicht in diesem falle im
unteren bereich dessen uns bewegen was
man generell also bei brennen zu
erwarten hat man muss dazu gleich noch
wissen dass also insbesondere auch die
dioxine die ja immer besonders viel also
ängste auslösen sich also nahezu
ausschließlich an rußpartikel gebunden
finden nach solchen wand ereignissen
also da ist es zielführend wie es hier
auch geschehen ist eben ganz gezielt
diese russ rückstände zu untersuchen
und da können wir jetzt sagen dieser
hinsicht ist das ein russ je daran war
auch lee ist irgendwie bei jedem wohnung
spawn zu erwarten wäre
in dieser hinsicht völlig unkritisch da
wir aber hier mit einer vielzahl von
substanzen in einer industrieanlage zu
tun haben die also natürlich sich nicht
vergleichen lässt mit irgendeiner
wohnung ist es richtig dass man noch
einmal gezielt nach dem jetzt kenntnis
des stoff inventars besteht noch einmal
gezielt zusätzliche untersuchungen zu
machen
aber wie ich vorhin schon sagte und wie
auch die kollegin gerade des bahnhofs
ihnen ja schon vermittelt habe sind das
untersuchungen die man wirklich also aus
maßnahmen einer sehr strengen vor so ein
sehr strengen vorsorgeprinzips werden
sollte was dazu dann an weiterungen
vielleicht zu bedenken ist das müssen
wir den weiteren untersuchung sga
überlassen dazu gehören natürlich an
dieser stelle nicht sagen prophetische
gaben maße ich mir nicht an
aber nochmal also wenn wir hier
dann sagen wir schadstoff gefunden
ermitteln sollten dann ist mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
davon auszugehen dass das konzentration
sein werden
die um in dieser begrifflichkeit zu
bleiben also nicht im gefahrenbereich
zuzuordnen sind sondern im risikobereich
und dass dann die daraus resultierenden
maßnahmen auch wiederum
vorsorgemaßnahmen sein werden so viel an
der stelle von mir
[Musik]
ja jeden tag auch von meiner seite damen
und herren zunächst mal möchte ich die
gelegenheit auch nutzen mich bei allen
zu bedanken bei den helfern der stadt
leverkusen der berufsfeuerwehr nach dem
landesumweltamt in nrw für die
unterstützung in den vergangenen tagen
sind natürlich auch in gedanken bei den
angehörigen der verstorbenen kollegen
und der weiterhin auf zwei vermissten
kollegen
wir wissen aber auch auf der anderen
seite das für die bürgerinnen und bürger
in den betroffenen wohngebieten ist eine
derzeit sehr belastende situation ist
haben dafür die hotline eingerichtet
damit sich die betroffenen bürger aber
auch bei uns dann melden
nach wie vor haben wir an der
einsatzstelle noch die suche nach den
beiden vermissten kollegen
das hat für uns im moment absolute
priorität
und das ist auch der grund dafür warum
aufräum und sicherungsarbeiten am
einsatzort auch nicht mit der
wünschenswerten geschwindigkeit von
statten gehen können nebenbei der erst
dann richtig loslegen können mit den
aufbauarbeiten wenn wir die beiden
kollegen geborgen haben die
stabilisieren derzeit die gebäudeteile
entfernen das löschwasser produktrechte
und dabei kann es dann und das wird es
eine andere auch an wahrnehmung gewesen
sein
zu einzelnen geruchsbelästigungen auch
kommen deswegen haben wir die luft
messwagen nach wie vor im einsatz
werkzeuge überwacht dann kontinuierlich
auch dass keine weiteren gefahrstoff für
die umwelt gelangen und das ist auch ein
messwagen der einsatz
ganz klar ist an der stelle dass wir
ganz eng auch mit den zuständigen
behörden zusammenarbeiten um die
unfallursache
auch restlos aufzuklären die bereits
gestarteten reinigungsarbeiten im
stadtgebiet wir haben ja an einer stelle
auch bereits in mittelbarer nähe damit
begonnen die werden natürlich weiter
intensiv fortgesetzt an den stellen wo
es geht wo wir ran dürfen
wir gehen auch weiterhin den hinweisen
nach wir haben die hotline geschaltet
mittlerweile 300 tausend anrufe
eingegangen
wir registrieren dass alles deswegen
wichtig dass sie auch weiter diese
hotline nutzen werden es aber auch noch
mal deswegen deutlich verstärken kamen
dann vor sofern wir dann auch in der
lage sind dort auch tätig werden zu
können
kontakt zu den bürgerinnen bürger
aufzunehmen um den mit den
reinigungsarbeiten dann auch zu beginnen
wir haben auch die gesagt eigene
analysen hergestellt dazu wir gleichen
das auch mit den laden auf ergebnissen
ab so dass wir auch im moment keine
abweichenden ergebnisse vorliegen haben
und werden dass weitere
untersuchungsprogramm was angedeutet
worden ist weiterhin auch eng mit dem
landhof abstimmung
wie gesagt alle verfügbaren gebäude
reinigungskräfte gerätschaften
materialien externe partner werden
zusammengezogen
damit wir so schnell wie möglich mit den
reinigungsarbeiten auch vorankommen
damit die belastung für die bürger und
bürger an der stelle so schnell wie
möglich behoben werden kann
vielen dank
fragen über fragen also dass eine
[Musik]
generelle hat in harmlos
angehörige hatten die frau und das
zweite test nicht bestand haben sollten
das land so wie das jetzt vorgeschlagen
wurde das verfahren hat was wir nach dem
tanz drin weil ich dachte ja also das
was schon gedanken wenn du das auch so
gesagt ich würde den freund hat mir
jetzt immer neuen platz her
richtig ist dass wir wissen zu jeder
tages und nachtzeit wissen was in
unseren tanks enthalten ist
richtig ist auch dass wir diese
unterlagen zusammenstellen diese stoff
datenblätter zusammenstellen ich halte
datenblätter zusammenstellen und die
dann als konvolut den zuständige behörde
übergeben das ist mittlerweile
vollumfänglich passiert wir haben das
rausgegeben so dass die eine aussage
genauso richtig ist zu sagen wir wissen
was drin ist im inventar weil wir dann
natürlich unterlagen und entsprechenden
dinge haben dass andres dass wir die
dinge zusammen geschoben haben und
übergeben haben ordnungsgemäß und zwar
ordnungsgemäß weil die liga weiter das
hat gestern einen termin stattgefunden
auch im größeren kreis wie die
ermittlungen sind aufgenommen worden und
wir sind natürlich gehalten
auch diese unterlagen an die
ermittelnden behörden in summe zu geben
wie geht es da unter anderem
minute polizei zu sehen die behörde die
dezernate und natürlich auch das laden
auf das heißt wir sind dann schon daran
gebunden sämtliche kanäle zu bedienen
also das war der grund warum das bisher
nicht
bis heute ist er bis heute morgen raus
geschickt und gestern abend sind glaube
ich die ersten dinge rausgeschickt von
heute morgen die anderen gäste haben
glaube ich kann die erste e-mail raus
und heute morgen die anderen
machen werde ich von mal und der urlaub
kann vielleicht ergänzen das macht
vielleicht sinn also aus unserer sicht
ist es sicherlich positiv zu bewerten
dass die rußpartikel keine bedenklichen
stoffe gezeigt haben
und ich habe ja eingangs auch gesagt
wenn es dabei geblieben wäre würden wir
heute auch entwarnung geben insofern
kann man sicherlich als erster in
warnung betrachten
auf der anderen seite möchten wir aber
der bevölkerung so viel sicherheit wie
möglich nehmen und eben deshalb aus
vorsorglichen gründen auch auf mögliche
weitere stoffe die sich jetzt aus den
informationen die wir heute vorliegen
haben ergeben und werden deshalb auch
weitere untersuchungsprogramm
durchführen das ist so gut formuliert
dass ich wirklich nicht ergänzen
[Musik]
wann werden diese informationen der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht
überwiegend in der sache
dass dann die ergebnisse
wir haben diverse anfragen von anwohnern
und anwohnerinnen bekommen dass die
rußpartikel aus niederschlägen hier
entfernten haben und ich wissen was wir
machen wollen vielleicht können sie
nochmal sagen die anwohner finden damit
umgehen sollen dürfen sie ihren rasen
neben dürfen die ihre auffahrt fäden ich
denke er nicht mehr so lange
transportiert einmal die zweite frage
zuerst ja es ist natürlich im prinzip
eine relativ kleine probe die wir dann
analysiert haben den zwei proben
analysiert die jeweils aus mischproben
eines größeren gebietes zusammengestellt
worden sind weil die partikeldichte
insgesamt ja dann doch nicht so groß war
dass man sagt wir können mit einem
partikel oder mit zwei partikelchen
auskommen mussten also sammeln und das
haben an zwei verschiedenen standorten
dachten wir haben auch versucht möglich
alle partikel variationen die wir so
gesehen haben auch damit zu erfassen so
dass wir im prinzip sagen können wir
haben nichts verpasst
ich gehe auch davon aus nach allen
informationen die ich mittlerweile
bekommen aber von anderen bürgern die
noch partikel kundendaten teilweise auch
fotos zugeschickt bekommen haben dass
all diese partikel sehr ähnlich sind in
der struktur und auch in der konsistenz
und zusammensetzung so dass er
eigentlich noch glauben dass diese
beiden proben schon sehr repräsentativ
sind und insofern also auch die
analysenergebnisse repräsentativ für den
gesamten russ fallout der in der nach
diesem unfall runtergekommen ist sein
müssten
hinsichtlich der untersuchten stoffe
natürlich nur wird das gerade ist die
begrenzung die wir getan und die eben
dann jetzt dazu führt dass wir noch vor
deutlich weiter untersuchen programm
anschließen
[Musik]
also die frage können wir auf dem podium
wahrscheinlich keiner beantworten weil
zuständig für die überwachung ist die
bezirksregierung köln und wann die
welche dinge veröffentlicht kann jetzt
seriös von uns hier sicherlich keiner
beantworten noch mal wir haben ein
bisschen was sie denn in den tanks drin
ist wir haben dazu die entsprechenden
datenblätter die werden wir
veröffentlichen wir natürlich nicht
können wir nicht dürfen wir nicht aber
wir stellen hat sich sämtliche
datenblätter sämtliche stoffe traten
auch den zuständigen behörden zur
verfügung
und das haben wir getan das heißt das
ist dann rahmen der der aufklärung der
unfallursache absolut geboten und das
tun wir das haben wir erledigt und das
ist jetzt quasi dann sache auch der
zuständige mittel den behörden also
soweit die pressekonferenz aus
leverkusen die große nachricht die wir
euch jetzt ja noch mal zusammenfassen
können ist dass das landesumweltamt
angibt sie haben hätten bei den proben
die sie genommen und analysiert haben
keine großen giftigen messwert oder
keine großen messwerte gefunden was die
wirklich giftigen inhaltsstoffe angeht
ich lese jetzt hier bei euch im chat
sehr viel skepsis was das ganze angeht
wir können das ganze erstmal genauer
analysieren und auseinander nehmen uns
angucken
gemeinsam mit dem toxikologen professor
daniel dietrich von der uni konstanz ich
hoffe er ist schon da ist ja guten tag
professor dietrich
sie haben das ganze gerade mitverfolgt
es gibt jetzt bevor wir nochmal zu den
einzelnen erkenntnissen kommen hier sehr
viel skepsis im chat dass das eigentlich
nicht sein könnte das ist so der tenor
bei einigen kommentatoren und
kommentatorinnen dass bei so einer
explosion oder bei so einem jahr bei so
einem unglück nichts eine so große menge
an schadstoffen freigesetzt wird dass
sie wirklich gesundheitsschädlich und
umweltschädlich ist was sagen sie als
toxikologe dazu ja gut man muss
natürlich die das gesamte ereignis
anschauen
das heißt wenn wir uns mal die wolken
anschauen wie sie sich da gestellt haben
haben wir am anfang eine verpuffung
gehabt mit viel weißem weißen dampf und
rauch das heißt hier ist einiges in die
luft gegangen das nicht reagierte seine
vollständige verbrennung stattgefunden
hat wenn man so will und erst im
nachhinein haben sich dann bei tieferen
temperaturen dieser starken schwarzen
wolken gebildet und ausgebildet
das heißt auch ich bin natürlich davon
ausgegangen dass wahrscheinlich pcb und
dioxine und furane entstanden sind die
sind sicher auch in kleinsten mengen
entstanden wobei ich jetzt auch sagen
muss ich habe mal in etwa versucht
abzuschätzen wie viel das sein könnte
und wir sind hier in geringsten mengen
die aufgrund der normalen konversion da
etwa stattfinden können
bei optimalen bedingungen eine einer
schlechten verbrennung und wenn man
diese gramm menge natürlich dann
vielleicht verteilt auf die größe der
hat der fläche dann ist es sehr wohl
möglich dass dies sehr sehr gering sind
oder unter der nachweisgrenze
jetzt ist aber natürlich die situation
so dass es eine verpuffung gegeben hat
das heißt ein großer teil des materials
ist schon weg und ein teil verbleibt
noch vor ort und deshalb ist es sehr
wohl nachvollziehbar dass keine
politischen aromatischen
kohlenwasserstoffe frano dioxine
wirklich nachzuweisen sind
da müssen wir glaube ich noch mal ein
bisschen von anfang an einsteigen also
sie haben aus der farbe der wolke
abgeleitet dass zuerst keine also eine
hohe verbrennung stattfand und dann
keiner das habe ich richtig verstanden
nicht dass es keine verbrennung gegeben
hat sondern dass das bei tieferen
temperaturen stattgefunden
am anfang wenn man gegen die masse an
material da ist und seine spontane
verbrennung gibt wie bisher auch gesehen
haben dieser weißen wolke ist meistens
eine vollständige verbrennung liegt am
meisten seine vollständige verbrennung
vor und wenn später dann das richtig so
richtig quandt ist es bei tieferen
temperaturen also und muss mal kurz was
sagen hier wir haben einen call und
hinterlässt keine rückstände von dioxin
im ruß ich habe das ehrlich gesagt so
verstanden dass es durchaus rückstände
gab aber nicht in dem grenzwert bereich
der tatsächlich umwelt oder
gesundheitsschädlich sein würde ist das
so wie er sich das ist richtig das heißt
wir haben geringe mengen nachgewiesen es
ist auch zu erwarten aber sie sind nicht
problematisch jetzt gibt es hier auch
viele fragen weil immer wieder gesagt
wurde von seiten des landesumweltamtes
ja wir müssen noch mal gucken was andere
analysen angeht also wir müssen noch
weiter gucken nach den stoffen wir
wissen noch nicht ganz was da drin war
der herr von currenta von den betreiber
hat gerade gesagt wir haben die
inhaltsstoffe weitergegeben können sie
das nochmal genauer erläutern da habe
ich auch so ein bisschen innerlich mit
den schultern gezuckt und dachte so okay
was heißt das denn jetzt nicht wieder
sie wissen was drin weil sie es nicht
muss natürlich auch ein stück weit das
erraten aber es ist tatsächlich so wie
ich das verstanden habe dass currenta
die gesamte stoff liste an das
bezirksregierung köln
eben hat da wird ja auch gerne wissen
was für stoffe waren lassen wenn in
welchen quantitäten und daraus kann man
in etwa abschätzen oder vermuten was wir
zwischen verbindungen entstanden sein
könnten
was ich aber sagen was diesbezüglich ist
natürlich schon dass die wichtigsten wie
es auch beispielsweise der drk genannt
hat dass wir die wichtigsten stoff
verbindungen stoff klassen die vereine
dioxine bezüglich aromatische
kohlenwasserstoffe
und ähnliche in sehr geringen mengen
vorhanden sind das ist schon mal eine
super gute nachricht was jetzt sowas ist
weiterhin geht und da muss ich wirklich
sagen dass ladung hat hier sehr gut
gearbeitet und gut kommuniziert sie sind
vorsichtig sie wollen abschätzen was für
zusätzliche verbindungen eventuell
entstanden sein könnten
und nach diesen substanzen zu suchen und
auch die zu quantifizieren
das ist nicht eine einfache aufgabe weil
die analytik nicht sehr simpel ist erst
heute gerade fragen das ist so das erste
was ich ja auch im chat leser bei
unseren userinnen und usern die
natürlich sich fragen wir sind doch in
einer welt wo man schnell wissenschaft
machen kann man schnell analysieren
andere analysieren kann was da drin ist
warum dauert das jetzt so lange warum
kann man jetzt nicht schon sagen was da
drin war können sie das vielleicht noch
mal genauer erläutern warum ist
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern
wird
ja vielleicht vielleicht ein bisschen
böser kommentar von meiner seite
natürlich sind so sendungen
fernsehsendungen wie csi miami wo sie
klar es war einfach mal was rein stützen
und den 20 nanosekunden haben sie dann
die antwort das ist wirklich fiktion was
existiert nicht sondern gerade bei
solchen stoffen die müssen sich mal
vorstellen
die meisten leute können sie nicht
vorstellen was koran und dioxine sind
aber vielleicht eine kleine analogie
wenn sie einen kaugummi kauen und sie an
zu einem ball machen und denn irgendwo
versuchen anzukleben dann müssen sie
diesen diesen tag um ihn richtig fest
andrücken als flache und flachen
kaugummi dann klebte gut weil ich jetzt
können sich die struktur dieses uran um
diesen aromaten und auch dioxine in
einer ähnlichen form vorstellen und die
kleben sehr gut an hus partikel an
oberflächen etc
das heißt die muss man meistens runter
kriegen das heißt man muss sie da
extrahieren herauslösen und dann muss
man sie auch breiten so dass man sie mit
den massenspektrometer gut nachweisen
kann und nicht nur danach weiß es hilft
nicht auch den zuschauern nicht wenn ich
sage ich finde welche die szene sondern
ich muss wissen wie groß ist die menge
verteilt und ist es möglich dass leute
wirklich hier exponiert werden und das
ist der nächste punkt wenn wie zb diesem
kaugummi prinzip war dieser dioxin und
frauen an oberflächen kleben ist die
exposition das heißt die tatsächliche
problematik für den menschen relativ
gering weil sie nicht aufgenommen werden
können außer ich konsumiere gemüse
salate ich mehr rasen beispielsweise und
das gibt dann hole ich alle die ein und
aufgrund dieser eine ahnung kann dann
tatsächlich ein klar ganz geringer
anteil in aufgenommen werden wenn jetzt
eine hohe kontaminationen daher die ist
dabei ja nicht das ist eine wirklich
super gute nachricht da würde ich gerne
mal gleich darauf zurückkommen aber erst
noch mal zu einer anderen frage ich bin
kein fachmann
ich bin einfach nur jemand der denkt
okay wenn man untersucht so viel wie
möglich jetzt hat das wenn das bundesamt
landesumweltamt gesagt wir haben zwei
proben untersucht so mischproben reicht
das aus ihrer sicht tatsächlich wird das
war doch ein relativ großes
kontaminiertes gebiet ist das
ausreichend dann zu sagen wir gucken
wollen zwei stellen und dann analysieren
wir da und dann wissen wir was drin war
okay man muss natürlich überlegen wie
wie die situation sich darstellt auf der
einen seite haben wir den dem brand den
unfall
wir haben eine verbreitete oder
verteilung von stoffen und auf der
anderen seite haben die bevölkerung die
natürlich dringend auf eine antworten
200 verlässliche antwort wartet das
heißt ich mache hier eine mischprobe um
die wichtigsten stoffe anderen mann
nachzuweisen sind die vorhandenen jahre
mein sind die in größeren mengen
vorhanden jahren ein
und die antwort ist nein aber das land
muss ich auch wieder sagen auch korrekt
ist vorsichtig und sagt nein bitte
wartet noch wir geben gerne entwarnung
nachdem wir alles nach gemessen haben
und sichergestellt haben dass wir
mehrere proben haben so dass wir absolut
runde prozentig sich darauf verlassen
können dass die warnung dass kein gemüse
kein obst aus dem garten gegessen werden
soll dass diese rußpartikel nicht
berührt werden sollen
die bleibt weiterhin bestehen also
vorsicht im raum leverkusen in allen
kontaminierten räumen wenn man sowas
findet sollte man das auf keinen fall
selber aufnehmen sondern verstanden habe
die behörden informieren ist es eine
frage von johnny der fragt sich wie kann
man denn die umgebung reinigen also
jetzt er schreibt von pcb dioxin furan
aber wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe kleben die an diesen rußpartikeln
wie kann man denn so einen großen
bereich überhaupt reinigen
also es gibt es gibt ja vielleicht zwei
punkte die die mir noch im herzen liegen
diesbezüglich es kann sein dass wenn die
reinigungspersonal sehen was das
reinigungspersonal in vollen zügen
da steht was ist komplett weiß
eingeleitet das hat arbeitsrechtliche
gründe nicht gründe dass hier
tatsächlich ein toxischen stoff vorliegt
das arbeitsgesetz sieht vor dass wenn es
möglich wäre nur gedanklich dass solche
toxische stoffe vorliegen müssten solche
schutzanzüge angezogen werden also bitte
ich nicht hier verrückt machen jetzt das
zweite ich habe schon früher mal gesagt
es ist möglich mit seifen beispielsweise
und lösungsmitteln diese stoffe
herauszulösen von den oberflächen runter
zu kriegen und das wurde auch gemacht
bei größeren mengen bis zum beispiel bei
seveso der fall war oder bei vielen
alten deponien der fall war hat man die
erde abgegraben und die erde dann
komplett verbrannt bei sehr hohen
temperaturen das ist bei zwei spiele ab
1200 bis 1500 grad celsius dann löst
sich das tatsächlich in co2 und wasser
und chlorid auf ich habe jetzt einen
sehr kritischen zuschauer der schon die
ganze zeit kommentiert torsten dressler
auf facebook der sagt jetzt zwei proben
sind humbug und die wichtigste wäre die
probe fdp zentrum um eben den höchstwert
zu erkennen aus dem sich dann die
verteilung berechnen lässt
würden sie das so unterschreiben nein
warum nicht was sind beziehen wichtig
ist natürlich kann man im epizentrum
wenn sie wenn sie wollen bot gerade der
brand stattgefunden hat macht man eine
analyse das wird auch erfolgen das ist
mit sicherheit auch jetzt schon erfolgt
die analysen
was aber als wichtig ist was wichtig ist
ist dass man zuerst mal eine abschätzung
hat wie haben sich diese stoffe verteilt
kann ich einen stoff nachweisen der als
problematisch eingestuft wird und das
land tatsächlich auch gemacht und hat
nachgewiesen okay wir sehen keine
erhöhte oder kritischen dioxin und voran
werte und wir sehen leicht erhöht der
rußpartikel aber nicht und auch der
kassen diesem zusammenhang aber nicht in
einem maß was problematisch werde es ist
okay das vorgehen ist okay man muss aber
daran denken dass ladung war ganz klar
deklariert sie wollen die
vorsichtsmaßnahme weiterhin behalten um
weitere proben zu analysieren und das
noch weiter abzusichern
also ich würde da dem lanuv und auch
günther und auch der stadt köln und
leverkusen die chance geben hier
ordentliche arbeit zu leisten das ist
nicht einfach aber was sie bis jetzt
gemacht haben sie haben eine entwarnung
gegeben und das ist schon mal eine sehr
gute nachricht
also ich fasse das noch mal zusammen die
pressekonferenz hat ergeben dass es
durchaus dioxine nachgewiesen werden
konnten aber nicht in kritischen
grenzbereich im nicht im grenzbereich
der für umwelt und menschen schädlich
ist wir haben gerade uns erklären lassen
von professor dietrich von der uni
konstanz toxikologe dass sich diese
schadstoffe an die rußpartikel binden
und deswegen erstmal auch nicht so
gefährlich für menschen und umwelt sind
wenn man nicht auf die idee kommt die
zum beispiel im mund zu nehmen oder
anderweitig zu konsumieren oder
rasenmähen haben sie ja auch gerade
gesagt da kann das dann freigesetzt
werden hier geht es aber tatsächlich die
finde auch berechtigte und grundlegende
frage können sie nochmal kurz erklären
was an dioxinen bzw an pcb und voran so
gefährlich ist okay das gibt es
verschiedene situationen die wir uns
heutzutage anschauen
bei höheren konzentration von dioxinen
kann es zu einer krebsentstehung kommen
dies bedeutet aber nur wenn wir über sie
genau ich nicht hören sind sie noch da
ok danke
und das heißt man kann nach einer
langzeit oder exposition tatsächlich
eine geringe zahl an tumoren oder der
tumorentstehung nachweisen das bedeutet
aber immer bei hohen konzentrationen
gerade das bedeutet beispielsweise leute
die in der pestizid industrie gearbeitet
hat mit 70 und ähnlichen oder die mit
agent orange gearbeitet haben in vietnam
krieg die hatten eine hohe exposition
und da kann man eine leichte erhöhung
und tumoren nachweisen
es wurde auch berichtet in verschiedenen
untersuchungen dass es tatsächlich
dioxine mit der verminderten
spermienqualität zu tun haben also auch
pcbs und ähnliche das hier geht es um
auch wieder relativ hohe konzentrationen
im vergleich zu dem was wir tatsächlich
tatsächlich aussehen
das ist aber wichtig zu wissen dass wenn
wir von einer chronischen das heißt
nahezu lebenslangen exposition reden
oder über längere zeit von 10 20 25
jahre
dass es dann zu solchen reaktionen
kommen kann wenn wir einer erhöhten
exposition ausgesetzt sind
beim normalen expositionen wie wir sie
rote tag
wir haben jetzt mit seinen hänger in der
leitung
mal schauen ob professor dietrich wieder
kommt das ist ja meist mal das problem
wir haben einfach jetzt eine
internetleitung aufgebaut ich glaube
über suchen oder über skype und ja jetzt
in 20 gerade weg ok ich weiß nicht was
die noch mitgekriegt haben aber
vielleicht mal ganz kurz
es gibt es gibt auch natürliche oder
natürlich entstandene bei dioxine
die findet man vor allem in
tonmineralien und geraten da ist die
exposition von personen die
nahrungsergänzungsmittel zu sich nehmen
mit ton
einiges erhöht und da sind zum beispiel
quellen von der tagtäglichen exposition
nebst der durch industrielle prozesse
verbrennungsprozesse und ähnliches
entstandene dioxine
ich muss aber dabei sagen die gesamte
inhibition der samenqualität und so
weiter und so fort bei männern die
beruht auf höheren konzentrationen zwar
bis und das tausendfach höhere als was
wir jeweils da täglich sehen
das heißt wir können erst mal
vorsichtige entwarnung geben zumindest
sagt dass die ja die zuständigen
behörden in leverkusen in nordrhein
westfalen aber die vorsichtsmaßnahmen
bleiben weiter bestehen hat das
landesumweltamt auch darauf hingewiesen
es werden weitere untersuchungen
erfolgen mit hilfe der stoff liste die
der betreiber weiter gereicht hat wir
haben hier versucht zu beantworten warum
das alles nicht so schnell geht
ich lese weiterhin kommentare die sich
eine sofortige aufklärung wünschen ich
habe jetzt aber verstanden dass das
ganze eben seine zeit braucht und
professor dietrich hat dafür plädiert
eben den behörden diese zeit zu geben
ich danke ihnen für ihre erklärungen und
für ihre erläuterungen denn die sind
nicht ganz so einfach ein thema und
danke danke euch für die fragen und für
die kommentare und sagte erst mal für
sollte dafür jetzt vielen dank fürs
zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal und
schüsse